Tomorrow night, Donald Trump
gets a CNN spotlight.
And now Liz Cheney trying to make sure
part of that includes
the glare of his January 6th disgrace
as Trump prepares for a town
hall with New Hampshire
Republican voters.
Cheney's political action
committee buying airtime
on this network to broadcast
this ad narrated by Cheney
to bring it into your home.
The message,
she says the former president,
quote, is a risk
America can never take again.
Donald Trump is the only president
in American history
who has refused to guarantee
the peaceful transfer of power
rather than accept his defeat.
He mobilized a mob to come to Washington
and march on the Capitol.
Then he watched on television
while the mob attacked law enforcement,
invaded the Capitol and
hunted the vice president.
He refused
for 3 hours to tell the mob to leave.
There has never been a greater
dereliction of duty by any president.
Our great reporters
back at the table Fact check true
when it comes to the ad.
But if you look at Donald Trump
six months ago and Donald Trump now,
his position
among Republicans
in the polls endorsements
from Republican officeholders
is going up,
not flat, not down, going up.
Yeah.
I mean, Liz
Cheney has promised
to just essentially serve
as a reminder hey,
remember that Trump did this.
Remember that Trump did this,
especially on January six.
But that's already been discussed
and debated.
To your point,
a lot of Republicans obviously know
January six happened.
Some of them have doubts about
whether it was insurrection or whatnot.
But people are still lining up
behind Trump.
It seems like,
even though that
this is a literal reminder in an ad
it might not do much to sway voters.
Maybe remind those independents
in the midterms who said,
why are we still talking about
the 2020 election?
I know that
that was a legitimate election.
But she promises to try to shake
this tree to the very end.
She says it's that important.
The question is, you know,
with ads and trap, does she travel?
Does she join the Republican race?
Well, Trump
allies are already hitting back
at those saying
that she's just got a personal vendetta
against the former
president of the United States.
But recall,
she was on the committee
and they've been pursuing this
for a while now.
But when it comes to the presidential
race, look, he is he is way ahead.
You have all these
are the Republicans who are about
to get
in thinking about getting in,
but they're polling in the single digits.
And I'm hearing from Republicans on
unless something dramatic happens
at this point
that he is likely to
be the Republican nominee,
The question is,
where does they, the anti-Trump forces,
do they get traction anywhere
when many of the candidates
were waiting for Ron DeSantis,
who wants to make the point,
don't go back.
But he has at least so far,
even though Trump has Trump
superPAC has savaged DeSantis.
DeSantis has not returned the favor.
The question,
if Cheney does not get in
will will
anybody in the Republican field do that
or will
that just be
we need Trump's voters so much,
we have to be genteel about this.
Chris Christie,
the former governor of New Jersey,
is still lingering out
there as a possible one to do it
and look for him
to potentially run
a similar Adam told before
New Hampshire tomorrow evening.
But look, he'll decide
in a couple of weeks.
But there is no doubt
as we sit here in the middle of May,
the former president
is in a far stronger position
than he thought he would be
and most Republicans hoped he would be
at this point in the Republican
primary.
It is still important,
I think, to point out
this still has to play out.
There are debates coming on
the Republican side.
We'll see
if he actually attends them or not.
But what this shows,
the fact that he's doing a town hall
with New Hampshire voters
tomorrow evening,
he is trying to go back to that
well of 2016.
He's trying to recreate
sort of some goodwill
among those voters in the middle
and to kind of forget
the January 6th happened.
Of course,
he cannot forget that it happened.
We cannot
and should not forget that it happened.
So this is all part of the conversation.
But now he's comparing himself to Biden
so that's why some Republicans like
the economy was pretty good under Trump.
So it is a precarious position
for Republicans
that they did not think they would be in.
You make an important point that it is
may nobody votes until early next year,
but his position at the moment
is quite formidable.
We will see if somebody can take it,
take him down a notch.